well let's talk first about Donald
Trump's surge the Daily Mail says Trump
orders immediate search of hundreds of
feds into Chicago calling it a violence
scarred disaster then threatens to order
them into other Democratic controlled
cities including Detroit in Philadelphia
over mayor's objections well that's
that's we do have this other story about
a dozen plus mayors saying no and
demanding a withdrawal of federal forces
but at least in the context of this
story that's the basis that's basically
it so what are they doing they're doing
FBI DEA and ATF agents and they're gonna
be taking on gun crime now Chicago Mayor
Lori Lightfoot tweeted she won't let
federal troops terrorize the city but
she says she spoke to you attorney who
told her FBI DEA and ATF would come to
assist the city's anti-crime fight which
she supports so she public public public
versus private right yeah there Donald
Trump is the worst that's what you guys
are coming to help that's really great
thank you so much all they're terrible
these people I'm really excited for you
yeah you need more more bug-eyed but
more buck a lot more barely got a
haircut when when the lockdown happened
oh yeah so uh yeah and everybody was
like how come you get to have a haircut
she goes because I am on TV for what
yeah yeah yeah she was like cuz I have
to go on TV I need a haircut it's like
other people have to go on TV to and
they need haircuts I think she should
sleep too you know this caused huge huge
problem for the kovat protesters because
know the left didn't understand the joke
when a bunch of these politicians were
like we're locking down but we're gonna
go get haircuts a bunch of protesters
started making signs saying I need a
haircut as a joke okay and then the left
doesn't understand sarcasm or irony and
they literally thought people are good
yeah I saw that it's white listen you
can't make jokes on Twitter you can't do
it because the left doesn't understand
humor at all that's a good point that
that's why they get offended by
everything well yeah the the nuance of
language this this is what I've actually
talked about this at length with many
friends of mine it is that like when you
talk to me right now you hear the tones
that I'm writing you right and a lot of
the issue is the people that on the left
are reading the
jokes I say in quotes in the way in
their perspective the way that they're
feeling the way that they're insecured
that their place of you know nope zero
confidence so the way they're reading it
is a direct like attack and and they add
those the the nuance of anger and you
know the the feeling that they have the
emotional outbreak to those jokes making
those jokes a real thing in their head
and happy what it ends up being it's
like you lack the ability to understand
context know that worse than NPCs an NPC
wouldn't even even think about it they
wouldn't even it would be like hey Jack
to you nothing
right exactly age filter yeah yeah it's
like you say it's really funny because
um I posted earlier about the riots in
Minneapolis so this is this we're gonna
get into it the gist of the segment did
you know that riots and protests have
been ongoing across the country for the
past couple weeks people don't know this
like Olympia Prout running down highways
in Rochester a state of emergency in
Utah in in Georgia so I've got a bunch
of these things pulled up did you know
there's a protest camp in Philadelphia I
I didn't I didn't know that there is
there is a Jazz in Philadelphia yeah
because the media doesn't cover the
paths yeah cuz the media doesn't cover
this kind of stuff you know but I posted
earlier it's so for those of you who
haven't who didn't hear there's this New
York Times story that a pawn shop was
torched and carrying the riots and they
just found the corpse terrible of a guy
who was killed inside I wonder about
this this is crazy I first of all I
don't know this guy's I'm sad to hear
this person died and this is a really
horrific way be burned alive in a riot I
wonder if people were you know flyering
whereas you know this man whereas our
loved one was our brother our father
whoever this guy is his name wasn't
released apparently yeah and they're
walking around and they're asking he
went missing during the riots and then
it turns out he was in a building
someone torched it now that guy's dead I
posted that and in line with what we're
just talking about with this inability
to process complex information somebody
responded with you hate like to me
saying that like I basically hated black
lives matter and supported police
brutality and I was like well how did
you get that out of me saying like it
was it was a screenshot of the New Times
and I and I wrote playing for keeps
that's it okay
and the point I was making is that in
these riots people are losing their
lives like this is not a game
absolutely and then I get people saying
like why don't you you know condemn
police brutality and I was like what
does that have to do with what I just
said it's the rage filter yeah a joke is
that you go on Twitter and you say
something like I like pancakes and they
go why do you hate waffles yeah I didn't
say that'll actually very much like I
prefer waffles but I do like pancakes
you prefer waffles well what about
pancakes I like them - wait a minute I
actually do like waffles better you know
you get the broader right we could talk
about it anyway
no let's get let's talk about Minnesota
in Minneapolis and we'll talk about the
riots now so anyway a well that's the
gist of that story that they found a
body burnt to death in the rubble yeah
and that's the thing that nightmares are
made of man is terrible so how many
people have died it's like twenty eight
people I think and so far I think it's
way more than that looking at like
what's going on in New York and Chicago
alone I think it's over that number I
don't know exactly I haven't been
tallying that up cuz I just keep seeing
death everywhere and I'm just like this
is terrible
this way that I keep seeing it
everywhere and so directly from the
riots okay I think it's like high 20s
okay but if you want to be fair and
claim that the defund the police actions
yes them from all of that
absolutely that I think that's of course
fair because that it spawned it started
from the riots you know over over George
Floyd you know right and I think I'm so
they cleared out the New York Chaz
earlier today yeah pre-dawn raid
oh yeah that's all right yeah did you
know that there was a Chaz in New York
City I mean I knew about it yeah the New
York Times has been writing about it a
bit and they were like it's a homeless
camp now yeah that's that's what de
Blasio said he's like well there's
there's not a lot of protesters anymore
there's more homeless - than protesters
and right how was it I don't know it was
it ever yeah well so so here's what I
said you know with my experience from
occupy the moment you announce you're
occupying something homeless people rush
over rise like safety free stuff food
free food yeah and and well but safety
like protection from you know getting
your stuff swept up at least at the time
being so the police so they purged us
but the question I had earlier was when
they when they went
when the protesters demanded a defunding
of the police across this country what
is the end result been deaths deaths
more more people shooting crime
increasing like specifically shootings
and murders because actually a lot of
crime is going down yeah like like petty
theft and violent crime is down on the
whole right but shootings and murders
way way up like hundreds of percentage I
would much prefer people getting like
thieves like going running them up then
I'm gonna die I can explain something
very simply though please do one of the
things I learned is really fascinating
about crime rates throughout the world
has to do with cell phone technology so
when I was in Sweden a couple years ago
talking about their murder rate going up
the one thing everyone liked to claim is
that it's only gone up a very little a
bit and you know violent well violent
crime is going down across lethal crime
is going down across the board we're
only seeing a small uptick and it's all
you know ultimately you know things are
things are getting better it's not that
bad
what was explained to me of something I
never realized until then the reason why
lethal crime has been dropping
dramatically is not because people are
less violent it's because we have cell
phones so if someone gets stabbed and
you don't have a cell phone you go help
help someone's been stabbed you run
around try and find a phone person dies
right someone get stabbed you have cell
phone you immediately call 9-1-1 they're
there with the minutes they save the
person's life
murder becomes attempted murder or like
you know aggravated assault makes sense
so what we're seeing now in New York and
other places
they're saying Violent Crimes actually
going down but murders and shootings are
going up what that means is what
probably would have been a mugging has
become a murder before the defunding of
the police when the guns were being
taken off the streets the illegal ones
you know that guy would probably rob
someone with a punch to the face now
that he has a weapon he just puts a
bullet through his heart oh and so
murders are skyrocketing and violent
crime in general is going down what it
really means is crimes are becoming
lethal that's why I'm not saying we
don't know there for a fact it could
literally be like all of a sudden all
the violent criminals are like we quit
I'm amid the pandemic and then I'll send
a bunch of dudes pull out guns like
let's go murder and I mean did we not
want to add into the fact all the the
people that de Blasio is letting out of
the prisons everywhere or in California
or
all the other places where they're just
releasing prisoners or getting rid of
cash bail so that they come in and they
go back out again right away and it's
like do we not think about that in the
democratic cities that's actually
happening so you got to add that those
to the statistics it's like right that's
happening so Trump wants to send in the
troops I don't blame him I say true but
quite literally it's just it's just like
cops you know it's it's the funniest
thing about this is Trump's like the FBI
the DEA and the ATF are going to go
assist in law enforcement and they're
like troops sending in secret police and
it's like you've watched x-files yeah
you know there's a thing called the FBI
did you know they actually have offices
around this country yeah they're in them
right now what do you what is what do
people talking about everywhere even
even yeah right you know when it comes
to like CBP and ice and DHS and fps I'm
like you realize the US Marshals are
literally in courthouses across the
country right now I'm just I'm sorry I'm
flabbergasted because of how stupid this
is right you could literally lock up
someone go I need to tell you something
right now those secret police they're
everywhere they're there they're in the
building now it's secret police make
people think like did you know that
these people have been occupying your
city for like 20 years it's not the end
of the world how about this I've
actually uncovered this really really
devastating secret oh yeah this could
change the face of this country they
could reshape Oregon as we know it well
there's there's a lot of people don't
know this I'm gonna tell you guys all
right don't tell anybody if an tyfa
stops going to the courthouse the
violence is over wow that's powerful
imagine all of the different conflicts
where they were like we could have ended
the war if you just didn't go it's too
late the rest of Utah or the rest of
Oregon is already trying to secede
are they really yeah they're I mean
they've been talking that for a while no
but there's a petition now they're all
signing it trying to leave
so that's this really thing that's
actually happening let me let me show
you guys some stuff something so so
first of all we see this right more than
a dozen mayor's in Portland are joint
joining Portland in asking Trump
administration to withdraw federal
forces to stupidest thing in the world
because feds are all over the place all
the time
whatever here we have this story from
shadow proof shadow proof is run by
there's some journalists that I've known
about for a long time I followed it's
not like a very high-profile publication
it's very left-leaning but that's less
relevant other than I know some of the
journalists who do this and I believe
while they may be biased they're telling
the truth Philadelphia threatens protest
encampment with eviction but still has
no plan for unhoused residents you can
see where their bias comes in new what
they say is the encampment formed June
10th to provide shelter social support
and resources to Philadelphia Sun House
residents many of whom have been denied
access to housing and kovat pretension
hotels but its existence remains
threatened by the city which is
determined to remove hundreds of
unhoused people to prioritize the needs
of the baseball field upon which the
encampment has encroached okay they're
saying it's a homeless encampment wait
make no mistake this is a homeless
encampment this is a protest so this is
kind of like this the the the sort of
more homeless II version of the New York
Chazz okay but all of the chances have
been homeless camps this one
specifically aims like but this one is
specifically about getting them housing
and stuff now now I wanna make it very
clear I am NOT saying Trump needs to
send in armed federal officers to clear
out a homeless camp not at all I think
this is the kind of thing where you're
like we got to figure out how to solve
this problem right where do you put
these people you can't just like what
often what they'll do is they'll just
bulldoze their stuff and then be like go
away and that's not a solution it's
never it never has been
yeah you're right they literally just
moved to another part of the city but I
mean neither is just giving them all a
house no of course not you know that's
that's yeah that's not something that we
can just do like all right well each and
every one of you now here you go here's
the house for every one of you I worked
for work I worked for a homeless shelter
and I'll tell you man these people many
of them don't want to be in houses it's
a good point what
what people need to realize I remember
this when I used to I used to busk like
playing music in the subway in Chicago
alright and the funniest thing was like
the firt of friend who asked me what I
did like were you working and I was like
I've been busking like what does that
mean I played guitar in the in like the
subway like a homeless person and I was
like like a homeless person with $300
fiberglass guitar and a portable amp I
was like do you think those people are
homeless well I'm like you've not seen
someone perform it's like it's street
performing so I would do it and outside
of Wrigley and it's you know you make
money off drunk people you know yeah but
the one thing I realized was that people
would conflate hungry and homeless so
they would be like we need to feed the
homeless you ever hear that yeah
definitely all the time it makes no
sense I'm homeless
not foodless foods easy to get and so I
started you know when when I actually
had people realize people thought if he
was treat perform you must be homeless
and I was like I was doing it for fun
half the time I do it now lay on
Hollywood for fun oh yeah I love buskin
I used to busk in New York old meet me
and this other dude would just like jam
out acoustic punk rock songs on
Hollywood Boulevard fun and we wouldn't
make a lot of money we'd make a handful
of change but we were doing it because
we're yelling in public and just jamming
out it was like yeah and people out
there loved it but then you start to you
know experience what people think of you
and I was surprised to learn they can
flake these things so when I ended up
working for this homeless shelter as it
turns out but most of these people were
like I would not like to be in that
homeless shelter thank you very much
bye-bye
and they they want to be out in the
streets so how you solve that problem I
don't know the point is I'm bringing
this up just to show you that whatever
this whatever's been going on since the
start of these protests it's not over on
on July 10th Utah governor declares
state of emergency due to civil unrest
that was not even two weeks ago so Trump
is deploying more law enforcement and
the law enforcement is saying is about
crime but this is just stuff I'm pulling
up to show you that you know violent
crime in Atlanta Georgia governor
declares state of emergency calls up
National Guard this was just about to -
almost three about three weeks ago no no
yeah yeah about three weeks ago all this
stuff has continually happened did you
know that there was rioting and
vandalism in Olympia I didn't even know
where Olympia was this is only earlier
July 8th stretch of vandalism violence
escalates in Olympia Tuesday evening
into Wednesday you just you google this
you pull it right up it's been ongoing
for some time so we all we also have in
Rochester this is just from like two
days ago protesters shut down the
interstate highway
I heard someone mentioning it was like
that there been shootings and crime is
going up I don't know a lot about what's
going on but the MIT but mainstream
media doesn't cover this stuff no they
don't want people to know that people
are actually writing I think they don't
care I think they're pushing a narrative
that everything is Trump's fault and if
it doesn't fit that bill then they don't
they don't go to that and and that's
what like that's what I keep seeing it's
awfully biased as far as I'm concerned
because I watch him you know I listen to
what he's actually saying thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you